to solve percentage problems quickly
let's look at another special trick
twenty five percent of 440 here if you
use the traditional approach then it
will take us some time let's use the
fraction approach 25 is 1 over 4 and
after solving this we'll get 110 so 25
of 440 is 110. similarly how can we
solve these two examples 50 is one half
so after dividing to 48 by 2 we get 124.
didn't we get the answer quickly 33.33
is 1 over 3 and after solving this we
get 33.
so we can see that the fraction approach
gives us the answers quickly if you want
an important chart for fractions related
to percentages you can find it here
pause the video and take a screenshot as
this will help you a lot using the
fraction trick can you give me the
answer to this in the comment section
don't forget to share this video